[Musica]
chi sono beh nella mia presentazione
sono un architetto per me è un
architetto è colui che nel progetto
rappresenta le istanze dell'uomo
io mi occupo di architettura e design
progetto edifici ambienti spazi oggetti
in cui la funzione principale l'aspetto
più importante è rispettare le esigenze
per cui vengono realizzati possiamo dire
quindi che se rispettiamo questi
obiettivi abbiamo fatto un buon progetto
state vedendo che non vi sto parlando di
estetica ma di requisiti rispettati
lo so che è un po difficile magari da
comprendere a quello rispetto a quello
che intendiamo tradizionalmente per
bellezza ma per me bellezza è l'insieme
di leggerezza nel senso di semplicità di
evoluzione divisione e di circolarità
non nego che l'armonia di forme e colori
servono per soddisfare la nostra
esigenza di bellezza e questo ce lo
spiegano le neuroscienze
ma nel progetto nel design è uno dei
fattori fondamentali ma non l'unico
leggerezza leggerezza come semplicità un
oggetto complicato strutturato che
riesce a divenire semplice è qualcosa di
valore
mi permette di poter usare di instaurare
un rapporto con lui
semplicità in un rapporto immediato
in un dialogo nella funzionalità
evoluzione evoluzione come ricerca
continua osare osare per sperimentare e
cercare di trovare nuove strade
riusciremo ad arrivare a quelle
soluzioni non si sa ma la cosa
principale e tenta c'e quindi porsi
nuove domande anticipa le anche
inespresse per cercare di trovare delle
risposte non è detto che le troviamo
però almeno si attiva il meccanismo
bellezza come circolarità perché
circolarità circolata nel senso di
apertura
se noi mettiamo in circolo un pensiero
un'idea questa può portare può diventare
motore di un meccanismo ed i risultati
inimmaginabili
quindi circolarità contro le barriere
per le aperture principalmente mentali
ma anche circolarità delle risorse ci
siamo resi conto ormai tutti i giorni
che le risorse sono sono limitate ne
stiamo facendo un uso sconsiderato sono
depauperate la bellezza dovrà porsi
anche questo approccio e bellezza come
visione visione anche un po onirica
essere un po visionaria utah provocare
ci permette di rompere gli schemi di
cambiare e poi è vero che sognare è
tipico del genere umano
se noi non segniamo un obiettivo non
intraprendiamo un percorso non iniziamo
neanche se vogliamo è perché l'umanità
sognato di volare
se siamo andati sulla luna e perché lo
abbiamo sognato
mi viene in mente un titolo di un
bellissimo libro che io amo e di cui è
stato fatto anche
il film ma gli androidi sognano le
pecore elettriche fosse quando questa
nuova intelligenza val ha la forza di
sognare come noi esseri umani dovremmo
rapportarci con un altro intelligenza
nel mondo quindi bellezza per me è
l'equilibrio di una serie di elementi di
fattori che si fondo si fondono nel
progetto che per me deve rispettare
alcuni parametri il rapporto tra forma
funzione evoluzione
quando abbiamo un buon design possiamo
parlare di bellezza di un oggetto perché
questo ci permette di fare bene e
agevolmente quello per cui è stato
pensato magari in maniera immediata
senza che noi ce ne accorgiamo
completamente tradizionalmente pensiamo
all'oggetto alla bellezza come oggetto
d'arte magari anche con un accezione
classica e il par tenore per
l'architettura
la venere di botticelli il david di
michelangelo
ma la bellezza la riscontriamo anche
negli oggetti nei manufatti di uso
comune
vi faccio un esempio parliamo di un
oggetto semplice comune quasi che noi
riteniamo banale una penna una penna che
ci permette con la sua funzione di far
fluire il nostro pensiero sulla carta
tramite le nostre dita il disegno e la
scrittura manuale sono il primo esempio
di traduzione del pensiero umano
immateriale in qualcosa di concretamente
visibile
guardate la complessità che ci sta
dietro
ci vuole esperienza c'è una
stratificazione di codici di ritrovati
nel tempo una cosa complessa che ha
costruito l'uomo e di cui ne esistono
varie situazioni
un oggetto semplice ci permette tutto
questo
e allora perché dobbiamo andare a
cercare a volte la complessità quando lo
abbiamo sotto gli occhi
l'infinito con una semplice penna lo
tracciato io ho dato un significato
grandissimo quindi forma dicevo
l'oggetto deve essere immediato attivare
subito un rapporto sensoriale tra me e
lui comunicare in maniera immediata le
sue caratteristiche non essere
sovraccarico di situazioni che non mi
permettono di instaurare immediatamente
il dialogo con lui
parlando di forma andiamo a vedere un
altro oggetto comune che riteniamo
banale che tutti quanti noi abbiamo
esplorato abbiamo utilizzato un vaso
anche qui la forma deve essere immediata
deve metterci in con questa sensorialità
in rapporto con l'oggetto non deve
crearci barriere anche quando
utilizziamo materiali inusuali
comunemente ritenuti poveri riciclabili
entrambi vetro e cartone però la
bellezza sta in quello che contiene
tornando alla nostra penna abbiamo
parlato di forma parliamo di funzione la
funzione fondamentale perché è una penna
che agevole scorre fluidamente mi
permette di continuare il mio pensiero
di poterlo esprimere di ragionare di
aiutarmi la mano mi sta aiutando a
ragionare se invece si inceppa si
inceppa questo meccanismo quindi la
funzione importante abbiamo parlato di
forma funzione
andiamo avanti un oggetto banale
semplice che utilizziamo tutti quanti in
tutti noi siamo seduti su
le sedie la funzione è quella di sedersi
ma come dicevamo prima evoluzione
ricerca ancora senso sederci e basta ce
lo possiamo permettere io lì la mia
postino che ormai mi accompagna in tutti
i giorni in tutti i luoghi perché ho il
portafoglio pieno zeppo di tessere
fedeltà non di carte di credito a mi
dispiace ma di tessere fedeltà che è
zeppo così non so più dove metterlo il
tablet o lo smartphone che deve
diventare sempre più funzionale quindi
sempre più ampio tutta una serie di cose
dove li metto questi va bene posso pende
una sedia più moderna due gambe a
cavalletto è una struttura unitaria
seduta schienale
però ho bisogno di risolvere questo
aspetto qua e allora la multifunzione
l'oggetto semplice quotidiano ancora
delle possibilità di esplorazione la
posso inserire è protetto e protetto
davanti dietro dal dal fatto che lo
possa colpire accidentalmente lo posso
prendere agevolmente quindi la funzione
importante in un oggetto anche in
un'opera d'arte alla sua funzione che
magari è quella di farci pensare di
farci ragionare di guardare le cose in
un'ottica diversa di attivare il nostro
pensiero è logico il fallimento o non il
fallimento o la possibilità di scelta
con quella non possiamo fare questo come
possiamo fare quell'altro ma possiamo
fare altre cose questo ci permette di
esplorare e quindi una scelta e la
libertà di scelta e bellezza perché
possiamo scegliere a cosa dare priorità
quindi la circolarità abbiamo parlato
forma funzione circolarità perché la
circolarità delle idee importante
l'apertura la bellezza non può vivere
nella chiusura secondo me ha bisogno di
apertura e in particolare apertura
mentale rompere le barriere eliminare le
barriere aprire abbiamo parlato
circolarità quindi come apertura ma
anche apertura verso un mondo che ormai
deve risolvere problematiche essenziali
come quello delle risorse che non
abbiamo scoperto che non sono più
limitate mustang di vento
quando sempre più limitate perché noi
siamo sempre di più e quindi pensare in
maniera circolare ma pesa in maniera
circolano è la prima cosa al utilizza
risorse il nostro pensiero piegare
quella linea lineare a cui siamo
abituati forzarla per arrivare a pensare
in maniera sistemica
la nostra società è sempre più
caratterizzata da complessità e
sistematicità e allora la sistematizzati
permette di scomporre il problema delle
menti semplici e poterli riutilizzare la
riparabilità la trasformabilità noi
abbiamo bisogno anche di cambiare di
trasformazione possiamo cambiare gli
oggetti senza cambiare tutto l'oggetto
si cambiando solo la pelle perché la
bellezza tutto quello che abbiamo detto
noi possiamo usufruire di bellezza ma
non deve essere risultato poi questa
questa è una isola di plastica
quindi se tutta la bellezza che ci sta
dietro poi risultato che noi non vediamo
sarà questo dobbiamo interrogarci cosa
muove la bellezza il futuro appartiene a
coloro che credono nella bellezza dei
propri sogni
ho preso questa frase di helen eleanor
roosevelt per dire che la bellezza dei
nostri sogni
deve anche interpretare che il risultato
non sia questo cosa muove la bellezza
siamo noi che muoviamo la bellezza
quando il vento muove un campo di fiori
è bello il vento è bello il campo dice
ma è la nostra percezione che muove la
bellezza come lo possiamo fare in tutte
le azioni quotidiane
ogni giorno negli oggetti parafrasando
una frase famosa la bellezza salverà il
mondo
sì ma se saremo noi a volerlo se per
primi salveremo la bellezza grazie
[Applauso]